1 une page cinéma pour terminer ce
journal à partir de demain sur les
écrans un film d'action américain
le titre est extrêmement bref speed
laventure elle dure deux heures n'allait
d'ailleurs pas y chercher autre chose
que de formidables cascades et un
suspense haletant voyage en autocar un
voyage très mouvementée avec pascal
deschamps et emmanuelle b les
distributeurs du film n'ont pas su
traduire le titre anglais pas la peine
speed key monde comprend vite et ce
n'est aussi ses précieux comme howard
payne le méchant à 12 h
il a une heure et 56 minutes c'est pas
bon cru pour rafler trois millions de
dollars en menaçant de faire sauter un
bus tu dépasse les 50 miles à l'heure
la bombe est amorcée repasse sous la
barre des 50 miles la bombe explose
speed str ici comme dire trois mots
gentils ils à 1h56 pareil pour mettre
des bâtons dans les roues du premier
speed comme jan de bont directeur photo
piège de cristal précis de réaliser son
premier film avant le début du tournage
gagnent de bondt s'était fait opérer du
coude
vous avez un problème de ligament et
malgré ça pour tous les gens qu'il
connaissait qui avait déjà travaillé
avec lui il a été fidèle à sa réputation
il n'aime pas quand la caméra est fixe
il veut de la souplesse il veut du
mouvement en fait ils recherchent
toujours l'excès exprès
personne ne descend de sa vue saura-t-on
fric plus rapidement si tu fais preuve
de générosité et il te reste plein de
monde qui trop l'air d'accord distant
seront des personnages n'ont pas de
psychologie ils sont là pour participer
à l'action du film et c'est tout
l'action c'est le seul moteur mais j'ai
quand même voulu faire de mon personnage
quelqu'un d'humain d'en faire votre
voisin de palier qui tout d'un coup fêté
plus mr je suis toujours le même genre
de personnage de toute façon on ne me
fait jamais joué de rôle de gentil et
vous savez pourquoi
pascal essonne ford ne veux pas me
laisser pourtant j'ai le même chapeau
que lui mais il sait que sous chapeau
c'est démoniaque speed excité enfin
comme les spectateurs qui n'oseront plus
prendre ni l'autoroute milo bus ni
l'ascenseur 1000 avions pendant huit
jours après avoir vu le film
jan de bont entre par la grande porte
dans le clan des réalisateurs de films
d'action on n'ose imaginer ce qu'aurait
été son film s'il n'avait pas eu mal au
coude